welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition in this video
we're breaking down the new horror movie
relic the 2020 film has a lot to unpack
from it
and throughout this video we'll be going
over our interpretation of the film
and the true meaning of its ending
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out yet then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
if you enjoy the video then please drop
a thumbs up as it massively helps us out
and if you're still not subscribed to
the channel then make sure you do as we
drop videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown
of relic okay so relic predominantly
follows three women from the same family
they are edna an elderly widow in her
winter years
kay her daughter and kay's daughter sam
the movie is very much about lineage
inheritance and how we must care for the
ones closest to us
as we are probably fated to follow in
similar footsteps to them as we grow
older
though the movie apes hereditary in many
ways i found that film had a far more
bleak ending than relic
which depending on your interpretation
is about acceptance
and love the movie opens with kay and
sam arriving at edna's house
after neighbours have noticed that she
hasn't been on the property for a long
time
kay and sam are sort of estranged from
edna
and they've pretty much abandoned her to
go and live their lives
likely seeing her as an inconvenience
rather than an actual person
they arrive to find her missing and thus
they call on the police to track her
down
edna randomly returns to the house one
day as if nothing has gone on
and on the surface it seems like she's
suffering from dementia
now in order to talk about edna and my
take on the ending
i have to talk about the house itself
and what it represents
we see that it is very much in a state
of disrepair and symbolically this also
speaks to edna's mental state which we
learn has started to deteriorate
there are scattered notes throughout the
property that all contain certain
messages
and these perhaps indicate her actual
thought process
and what goes on through her mind i've
sadly known a lot of people that have
suffered from dementia
and it's clear that rather than having
complete thoughts
most of the time they act on instinct
and a scatter shot though process that
is represented here
edna is clearly lost with no one to
guide her and she puts food out for a
dog that died years ago
leaves the bath running and is clearly
in need of care
kay makes up excuses such as having work
but deep down i think she knows that she
has neglected her mother
now though the movie sort of teases at
the supernatural i do think that there
are real world indicators as to what's
going on
i will however be going through both
possibilities and you can decide what
ending
you interpret the film is having now
black mold is often used throughout the
movie
and in real life this can cause a lot of
issues if you've seen our haunting of
hill house breakdown
you'll know that the mold in that could
also be used to explain the supernatural
occurrences
and i believe that it makes a firm case
here black mold is extremely toxic
and over time it can infect your brain
neurons and cause a wealth of changes
living amongst black mole can cause
dizziness depression
breathlessness hallucinations and even
death it's said throughout the film that
there may be a presence in the house
however i believe that it can be
attributed to a number of things
the boy with down syndrome could have
potentially been coming into the house
and going into the walking cupboard
though his parents told him not to
he still did hang around the property
and may have re-entered when he thought
edna was gone
there's also the possibility that the
banging on the wall is edna herself
who got lost in the labyrinth-like area
within the house
and due to the mold this caused her to
hallucinate
and believed that the house was shifting
similar to what we see through the
perspective of sam
a giant clue that adds weight towards
this happens when kaye and edna hear
something in the walls
and they look up to see a giant mould
stain which i believe highlights what is
really going on
edna was of course missing at this time
so it is definitely a possibility
there's also a large black mark that
appears on edna's chest
and later on k suggesting that this is
linked with the mold
family and the grounds itself at one
point edna tries to eat photographs
and bury albums in order to stop the
house from eating her memories
which i think represents living in the
property amongst the mold
has caused her memory to deteriorate
rapidly now the presence is felt
throughout the entire house
because in my opinion the mold runs
throughout the walls
and ceilings and thus it's impossible to
escape
whilst you're on the grounds trying to
navigate it eventually leads to you
trying to navigate through a labyrinth
which decays your mind and mental state
as mentioned earlier this is showcased
by sam
who finds an almost maze-like structure
within the walls
and she becomes lost now whether you
think it's something more sinister or
not
the mole was clearly put in the film for
a reason and it appears in kay's streams
when she recounts the history of the
location
we see that her family members have
lived on the grounds for generations
and is possible that their madness was
linked to the state of the property
and the mold infestation that's likely
been through edna's house
and the cabin that was incorporated into
the home kaye has dreams of an old man
in the previous versions of the house
and we learned that this was actually
her great grandfather he sadly died of
what appeared to be dementia
after being abandoned by his family and
i think this very much influences the
end and the choices that kay and sam
make
like most families kay wrestles with
putting her mother in a home
but compromises are made that sort of
show that the children and grandchildren
have changed things and are not going to
repeat the mistakes of the past
now the movie kind of takes a big turn
when kay sees edna stabbing herself in
the chest in the bath
the water in the bath overflows and
knocks out the power which makes kaye
try and find her mother in the darkness
she comes across her with her skin
peeling off revealing
somewhat of a demon underneath it now
you can take this as a possession of the
character
and that something has been living in
the house and on the grounds
preying on the family for decades
opposing that though
you could take this other form as the
complete difference in personality
that someone can gain through dementia
exploring the first option
the movie does take a supernatural turn
and it has k
fear for her life as she's chased by
this monster k
ends up running through the labyrinth
until she finds sam
together they manage to knock a hole in
the wall and nurse gain away back into
the house
the demonic figure returns and k beats
it with a pipe and she and sam make
their escape
however kaye hears her mother calling
her name and she recalls how her
great-grandfather was abandoned too
and instead of leaving edna decides to
return to her
she takes edna up to her bedroom and
peels off the rest of her skin
showing a rather pathetic creature
beneath she puts it on the bed and
cuddles up with it
and not long after is joined by sam we
then see a black mark on kaye's back
similar to the one on edna's chest and
they huddle together
with kaye likely being doomed to the
same fate that her mother had
now there are really two ways that you
can take this and either the demon on
the property has claimed another victim
and will continue this process with k
and sam or
there's something more subtle going on i
actually take the ending as somewhat of
a metaphor on family duty
that is disguised as something evil
throughout the last few years
kaye has watched her mother's mental
state deteriorate and she has tried to
flee from it
kaye clearly didn't care about the
character that much and even though
she was her mother she was happy to
leave her however
this ending shows me through edna
calling her name that she realizes
their family have all shared a similar
fate in which they were abandoned
and it's likely one that kay herself
will fall victim to
if she allows herself and sam to run
away the returning to this symbolic
demon
and caring for it instead of hating and
detesting it
shows that kaye is willing to look after
her mother rather than to spend her life
fleeing from a duty
she has accepted her responsibilities
and though i believe that the mold
made her and sam manifest visions of
something otherworldly
the simple truth of the ending is that
kaye and sam will not abandon edna
it's somewhat of a positive message
especially as
we have confirmation that the same
things will likely happen to kaye
however she has raised sam differently
and instead of allowing sam to run away
from everything
much like she did she will have a
brighter future
filled with the love of a daughter i
think in the final shot
sam sort of realizes what's going to
happen to kaye
and decides to stay with her so the
movie
is kind of a picky poison over whether
you see things as actually demonic
or as things that are caused by the
black mold personally
i lean more towards the latter
especially due to my experience with
people that have dementia
and though often at times it can feel
like you're dealing with a completely
different person to the one that you
knew
this other form is not something to be
hated and to run from
we must show kindness as it could also
happen to us one day
and thus i feel like relic delivers a
strong message in the closing scenes
now before we get into the rest of the
review i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the mcu
infinity saga to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the movie in the comments
section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of july and the set will be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay so what did i think of the movie as
a whole well
though this is going to be a slow burn
for a lot of people
i think that in the end the overall film
and meaning behind it are worth the wait
there's a lot going on here and though
the cast is rather small
they all make an impact horrors to me
are at their best when they also deal
with humanity
and it was gripping to see this play out
i don't think it quite matches the
stature of films like the babadook and
hereditary
but as far as horrors go i think this is
better than most released this year
and it will stay with you long after you
watch it
overall relic was great and it gets an 8
out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie so comment below
and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of this weekend's
other big release the old guard which is
going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server or at heavyspoilers on
twitter
as always thanks for making it till the
end of the video and you've been the
best i've been definition and hopefully
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
um